[Applause]
[Music]
on the first of July this year Canada
celebrated its one hundred and fiftieth
birthday now we told you all about this
in a previous video where we also showed
you some of the keys as to why Canada is
one of the most admired countries in the
entire world Canada it's divided into
ten provinces and 3 territories that
have so many unique regulations that in
2017 they actually had to sign a free
trade agreement among them however even
though this country has turned 150 in
perfect shape Canada is also facing
problems they face social political and
economic threats that could be
considered well pretty serious indeed
because as you probably already know
well unfortunately nothing is perfect so
in a previous video whose link I'll
leave at the end of this video as well
as in the description below we looked on
the bright side of things and Canada
ended up looking pretty darn wonderful
but in this video we're going to discuss
the main problems and threats that are
affecting Canada and well the first of
them it's got a lot to do with this one
hundred and fiftieth anniversary
a birthday somehow artificial not all
Canadians not even close
celebrated this one hundred and fiftieth
birthday we can find several different
reasons why but in order to explain them
we should first tell you about what
happens 150 years ago so let's jump back
in time all the way to 1867 on the 1st
of july of that year the territory was
still a part of the british empire but
it was on this day that the first
British North America Act was signed the
British North America Act of 1867 was a
law that United the three colonial
provinces of New Brunswick New Scotland
and Canada which was divided up into
Ontario and Quebec that very same day
into the Confederation of Canada on top
of these four provinces which still kept
quite a lot of autonomy a federal
government was organized to give them
some cohesion above this governments
there was still the British authorities
in fact to this day Canada is still the
monarchy and Queen Elizabeth the second
is still the head of state also and
although it might sound surprising
Canada didn't have total independence
from the UK until very recently 1982 in
fact that was right up until 1982 any
constitutional modification requires the
approval of the British Parliament
so as you can probably see from this
that lore in 1867 didn't result in a
completely independent country but dear
viewers I that's not the end of it there
are more reasons why Canadians dislike
this day the most important of these is
that when the settlers arrived Canada
well it wasn't an empty land
[Music]
the First Nations the Inuits and the
Metis
[Applause]
around 1.5 million inhabitants said
nothing to celebrate last July and those
inhabitants well they were the natives
of Canada it's a celebration of the
worst 150 years of indigenous peoples
lives but don't think of this as only a
historical problem the recognition and
integration of these peoples it
continues to this day to be a national
problem in fact the governments of
Justin Trudeau has made it a priority
consider what the Prime Minister had to
say on the 21st of June over this yeah
no relationship is more important to
Canada than the relationship with the
indigenous peoples Justin Trudeau but
now you might be wondering who are these
groups and what has happened to them
over the last 150 years according to the
Canadian Constitution there are three
large groups the first nations made of
more than 600 Native communities the
Inuits the people of the Arctic and the
met eats the result of mixing natives
with the new settlers
so Canada was not an empty land when the
settlers arrived it's actually estimated
that there were around 500,000 people
from these Native communities who signed
agreements with the British and the
French authorities they even
participated in the battles that
protected the independence of Canada
Canada would be American today if not
for the Indian allies who fought for the
crown Peter Russell
oh yes the US really did try to invade
Canada more than once well the problem
is that despite being the first people
in this land and despite the fact that
they participated and contributed to the
independence of the country the natives
suffered clear cultural persecution
yep as a result of that obsession some
how to create homogeneous national
identities Canada went through a period
of persecuting the natives for years
these people suffered the occupation of
their territories and were sent away to
reservations which sometimes didn't even
have the basic conditions that would
allow for their survival furthermore
both their language and their cultural
and religious rituals were sometimes
forbidden this persecution it reached
such a point that the authorities set up
a system of residences and boarding
schools for the children of native
families the government took the
children from the families and sent them
to schools where they would receive an
education which was fully Western so
that they could lose all aspects of
their cultural identity tens of
thousands of children they were educated
in this way
[Music]
[Applause]
and these schools they continued until
the 1970s
and the consequences they still have to
be dealt with today poverty rates much
higher than average there are many
broken families depression is rampant
and alcoholism and suicide rates are
higher than average
[Applause]
[Music]
these are the consequences of this sort
of persecution along with these racism
and exclusion were also very normal so
in 2008 the prime minister at the time
Stephen Hoffa apologized to these
peoples for the atrocities and
established the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission
Mr Speaker I stand before you today to
offer an apology to former students of
Indian Residential schools the treatment
of children in Indian Residential
schools is a sad chapter in our history
they've also paid hundreds of millions
of dollars in reparations that money
can't fix all these problems even today
Canada is still looking for the best way
to move forward from this dark period of
its history but now let's step back
forward to the present day and look at
the relationship between Canada and the
US oh well more absolutely Canada and
president from the break-up threat
Canada is very dependent on its
relationship with the United States they
are so dependent that we could almost
say that the Canadians would be unable
to live without their southern neighbor
indeed almost 70% of Canadian trade is
bound for the United States further the
industrial sector of both countries it's
strongly interconnected so this is a
special relationship and this is
something Justin Trudeau knows indeed he
said so in his campaign and as soon as
he reached power Lee concentrated his
international affairs into improving
Canada's relationship with the United
States and truth be told the
relationship that he built with the
bomber there was great
so thank you again for your leadership
and your friendship I know that our two
countries can achieve great things by
working together as allies and as
friends as we have done so many times
before some things we will probably
never agree on whose beer is better
who's better at hockey
[Music]
but now Trump's in office and is suing a
policy of protectionism Canada what
they've done to our dairy farm workers
is the disgrace it's a disgrace and so
what did the Canadian government do well
they set up something of a war room this
was an office dedicated to following all
the movements of the new administration
in Washington at first these strategy of
Trudeau and his people was buttering up
the American government and it kind of
looked like it was working the Canadian
Prime Minister even started a friendship
with Ivanka Trump Trump's daughter
Justin Trudeau brings Ivanka Trump to
Broadway show on welcoming Outsiders as
you can imagine this opened the door to
all sorts of wild rumors and speculation
the thing is they got on well and both
led a seminar on women in business that
Donald Trump himself mentioned in a
speech to Congress the help of Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau we have formed a
council with our neighbors in Canada to
help ensure that women entrepreneurs
have access to the networks markets and
capital they need to start a business
and live out their financial dreams
Donald Trump all right so this was all
great it seemed to be working really
well buds then all of a sudden Trump
attacked and accused Canada rather
unexpectedly of unfair competition
something that he also did with Mexico
it would be really dangerous for Canada
to suffer a restriction on trade
relations with the US so the
government's in Ottawa decided to start
the so-called doughnut strategy
consisting of influencing all
institutions around the White House
which would be considered as being in
the center that whole of the day
but the question it now becomes will
they achieve their goal only time will
say the first challenge is to
renegotiate NAFTA as Trump has demands
it now next up we need to consider
another potential crisis that could
threaten Canadian prosperity the real
estate bubble the prices in Canada's
housing market they have absolutely
skyrocketed they've increased 76 percent
and so if the loans that banks are
providing indeed family debt in Canada
is now among the highest in the world
have a look at this chart do you see the
increase in Canadian real estate prices
and then we've got to consider family
debt
[Music]
but as you might imagine this is set off
all sorts of economic alarms many
analysts foresee the popping of the
Canadian real estate bubble along with
all the consequences that that would
have on its economy and look almost 7
percent of the country's employments
belongs to the construction sector and
thanks to this mortgage boom three
Canadian banks are now in the top 20
banks worldwide in fact the market value
of the Royal Bank of Canada is higher
than that of any bank in the eurozone as
everyone knows the consequences of the
real estate bubble bursting would be
pretty dire so doing something about
this has become another priority of the
Canadian government the government's
it's trying to stimulate other sectors
while cooling down the real estate
market maybe the intention to increase
the arrival of immigrants by 50 percent
every year has a lot to do with this
more immigrants means more demand for
real estate but other experts they
disagree with this and state the
Canadian banks were not affected by the
2008 crisis and that they are quite a
bit more solid than other international
banks and also the economy in Canada
it's doing quite well and is gaining
strength after some pretty mediocre
years
anyway time will tell but this is a risk
that the government is going to have to
look out for all right so now let's move
on to the matter of public services the
waiting lists
in Canada health is a public service
which is managed and financed by the
governments with the citizens taxes of
course the system is considered to be
one of the best in the world
however they have recently had to deal
with some very serious problems most
important of all of these problems is
the issue of waiting lists according to
the Fraser Institute the average time to
see a specialist is 18 weeks that's more
than four months and the demographic of
the aging population and the increase of
life expectancy has made it difficult
for the system to cope this is all
resulted in tens of thousands of
Canadians of moving to the u.s. to
receive medical attention and lately it
is even popular to take our medical
insurance in the United States anyway
these are the main challenges and
threats to the governments of Justin
Trudeau like we said earlier not
everything and these sunshine lollipops
and rainbows but you know what we think
that the overall result of the Canadian
cocktail well we think it looks pretty
good so now it's your turn what do you
think of Canada and their systems do let
us know in the comments below and also
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for brand new videos every Monday and
every Thursday and also don't forget to
check out our friends at the you
consider media podcast they provided the
vocals in this episode that were not
mine and as always well thank you for
watching
[Music]
[Applause]